all right we are now live for another
live reading from my book reason
fulfilled by
revelation the 1930s christian
philosophy debates in france
and we're reading um a selection today
by maurice blondell one of the
uh four
different articles that i i translated
by him that are part of this book so
this uh while we're waiting for people
to show up and and get here i'll tell
you a little bit about this
maurice blondel was one of the major
players in these debates
he is probably
you know you could say among the top
three the three most important being
blondel either
and jacques mariten
also important are the rationalists emil
brejier and
leon braunschwig and then we have uh you
know a whole bunch of other people like
gabriel marcel also translated in this
book um antonin sertian also translated
and a whole host of of others who we're
going to get to
eventually and one of the reasons why i
generated this book in the first place
was to restore blondel's voice to
the debates a lot of anglophone scholars
that is people in the english-speaking
world
really didn't understand the scope of
the debates in part because jill so and
mara ten to catholic thinkers who are
quite hostile to blondel for various
reasons
managed to
essentially plant a false
understanding of of the scope of the
debates and what the debates were were
centered upon
and uh this stuff wasn't translated
until you know 2011 when this this book
came out so
um blondel responded both to jill so in
the the one i read uh several weeks ago
his arctic or his letter does christian
philosophy exist his philosophy and then
he responded to emil brejier who had
called him out in his own
uh presentation slash article in the
review de mere physique
so blondel you know shots fired across
the bow um fired some some shots himself
and that's what's going on in this piece
is there a
christian philosophy and it's a fairly
short piece um
pages 150 to 157
in this book
so it won't take us the whole hour
uh might even just be half an hour to
read this and then we'll we'll have some
time for q a
and discussion afterwards now this is
not a general ama this is about the
christian philosophy debates the
thinkers the topics and this this book
um so i you know i'm i'll i'll punt on
things that are that are not related to
that but i'm happy to answer questions
about about these matters
so let's let's jump in uh maurice
blondell is there a christian philosophy
published in the reviewed metaphysique
morale
uh in 1931.
my dear director i would not solicit
your hospitality if after the important
article mr emil bregier had published in
the june
1931 issue i had not received multiple
letters and identical questions
expressing my diverse correspondence
common surprise
unable in my state of health to respond
directly to each one and supposing at
any rate that among your readers many of
the silent ones might themselves wish
for some clarification on breger's
passages that drag me into the fray
i make recourse to your ever welcoming
friendship
i have to thank mr braille right away
for having been willing to call
attention to my work i've always
believed that work wanted it and called
it a philosophical one nothing else
he is the one who calls it apologetic
and of mere opportunity this is a
dispute that is not just terminological
one that does not concern just my own
personal efforts if it was only that i
would keep silent a dispute that does
not even bear just on the question of
christian philosophy
but that concerns the fundamental
attitude and the normative function of
pure philosophy
in order to respond to the questions
that touch on me personally it is
therefore necessary at the start to
distinguish mr brayer's own
presuppositions his method of discussion
and the character of his solutions in
any case this will be an occasion to
offer him a second and greater thanks
for with his so vast irritation with the
quasi-magarian rigidity of his theses
and
antithesis he forces his readers towards
a radical examination he pulls them out
from equivocations approximations and
oscillations one is often lured into in
a subject so complex and so delicate
one
quite rightly mr brahir sets us on guard
against one temptation
to conclude from apparent facts and
historical denominations like those of
christian philosophies encountered in
different times and in quite
heterogenous doctrines to the real and
intrinsically justifiable existence of
water perhaps only verbal conceptions
is to be duped by a mirage to be the
victim of an insoluble problem since the
problem then does not even exist
on many points his detailed critiques
inspired by this spirit of intransigent
intransigence scrupulosity
usefully bear down on and knock off
ruined plaster and jury rigged
concortisms on which it would be ruinous
to rely
still what seems to be
me necessary to maintain if we want to
be historically exact and doctrinally
correct
is that our authors multiplied
demolitions leave intact the hope and
the very outline of the building about
which he tells us not only that it was
never really built but that is
impossible to build
even to concede
how the literal correctness of many of
his partial allegations does not prevent
his global
denaturation of the spirit animating
fragmentary and imperfect attempts from
which mr brayer wants to retain nothing
how much beyond the notional oppositions
and ambiguities he rightly points out
the general interpretation he gives to
augustinianism to tomism or other
philosophical attempts unduly eliminates
what under inadequate vestments gave
life to and rendered possible the
continuity of an intellectual tradition
how are historians very dogmatic
rationalism
becomes irrational and seems to mutilate
history just as much as philosophical
speculation itself
these are what it would be possible and
very instructive to show following this
implacable critiques scholarly itinerary
point by point i cannot to my regret lay
it out in detail here where i should
also on the other hand have liked to
bring up
the truth of his just as severe
judgments upon descartes or maul brush
and before arriving at his case aimed at
me i will confine myself to examining
for a moment mr brahier's habitual
procedure in this article about or
rather against christian philosophy
what is the secret and constant spring
of his argumentation
he identifies philosophy
with its hellenic conception and he
identifies this conception with this
mass we will soon see gradually defined
with the outcome that anything going
beyond or contradicting this
rigorous rationality
is pitilessly cast outside of philosophy
itself
after that he's surprised that one could
close one's eyes to the evidence of an
incurable and absolute incompatibility
between the greek ideal and the
christian contribution
an object of scandal for a reason
perfectly conscious of itself
it is our turn to be astonished by this
dogmatism imposing itself by authority
without seeking to justify itself and
what are actually the articles of this
cradle or if the word displeases the
assertions of this intrepid rationalism
to affirm that quote the goal of greek
philosophy was to investigate the
rational consequently a movable and
fixed order that is in things
to attribute to that thought having
quote discover the exact and nevario
tour place that it occupies in the
eternal order to say that the
affirmation of the eternity of the world
that of an immovable order perfectly
satisfied the taste for beauty to bring
this notion of the immovable to that of
a periodic return to canonize this
pseudo idea of the world eternal quote
under the form of an indefinite cycle of
series of cycles
under the symbol of the servant serpent
swallowing his tail or the great year
and definitely bringing back to the same
events to conclude that quote all of
this forms a hole in a systematic
assemblage of well-connected theorems
and bearing on realities
that this is the dogma
outside of which there is no longer
philosophical reason or salvation
is this the last word about hellenism's
very history the perfection
of scientific and metaphysical
speculation in return
to envision the idea of a god
transcendent to the world to conceive
eternity as irreducible to time to see
in time less a physical reality than an
aspect of becoming and the condition of
growth
to find distinguishing between the
indefinite and the infinite to be
rational to recall that from its origin
on philosophy has not been a sophia but
a quest a progress an inventum semper
to recall and to develop its explicative
and enlivening double function to
enlarge science and the intellect and to
make them more flexible to the point of
understanding the dignity of singular
facts and human persons
to reconcile in thought as they are
reconciled in life the oppositions that
abstract understanding believes
incompatible to introduce everywhere a
genetic and dynamic point of view that
makes the physical and spiritual
universe an immense history and a drama
are these then what under pain of
absurdity
would remain excommunicated in the very
name of a cult of reason
that presents itself alone as the
contrary of an apologetics
and if just now we were surprised by
what brahir placed under the name of
hellenism must we not be surprised again
by what he proposes to us so that he can
be scandalized by it under the name of
christianity quote this worldless god
who throughout an eternity remains
inactive and then all of a sudden sets
himself to create according to his will
a god who changes nature in order to
incarnate himself who transforms the
order he has established a god who is
accessible to pity in short a history
a life a bounty
substituted for a universe of fixed
essences negligible individu individuals
and indefinite recommencements this is
how can we not employ the word
the caricature
that he presents in order to ridicule
and abolish forever the very possibility
of a christian thought
such judgments that one can understand
in the works of a calcius certainly
cannot be attributed to mr brejier but
why suggest them evoke them even imply
them effectively make use of them in
order to eliminate even the idea of a
possible harmony between christianity
stimulations and the initiatives of
philosophical research
after having shown that the christian
contribution was able to contribute to
the arrival of a humanism where the
problem of universal intelligibility
appears compatible and even in
solidarity with subjectivity in the
progress of the interior life
how does mr bray here not tolerate the
idea that such a dialectic of spiritual
activity is
truly philosophical that this process is
perhaps not closed that imminentism and
atulismo can only be only a set of first
steps preparing us and raising us to a
still more comprehensive conception of
the life that is both rational and
religious together
two
after these remarks one will doubtless
be less surprised at the ease with which
mr brayer tosses my my essay accion 1993
outside of philosophy by completely
abstracting from the method i made use
of by metamorphizing that book's
contents and by omitting
all of my conclusions reservations and
limits
what is perhaps more difficult to
explain is how he finds without any
doubt his own assertions to be coherent
assessments to us
seemingly discordant to each other
the problem of action he says such as mr
blondel raises us does not have any
special relation to christianity but
then by discussing this problem that
infinite aspect
how do you find itself
that i and
i do quote not philosophy but christian
apologetics
my work he adds
very closely resemble the problem of
serenity and the tranquility of the soul
which so occupied ancient thought
but then would we have to reduce
stoicism epicureanism and other schools
to a pure moralism lacking a universal
character without a physics or canonic
or theology
and after he's excluded from reason's
domain what is involved with the ethical
problem itself by casting all of
hellenic philosophy as a strictly
objective rationalism how how then does
he reintegrate within ancient wisdom a
preoccupation he had excluded and since
he assimilates maya quote apologetics to
this wisdom of the ancients
he therefore does the same with those of
the apologists but of who and of what
or how does he not see that once again
he fails to recognize the double
traditional function the speculative
function and the practical and
humanizing function of that philosophy
that from socrates on and even before
him
aimed at self-possession and at the
ideal of the wise man in his connection
with the universal order
but if in this point of view there is
already misunderstanding and denaturing
of the philosophical plan i pursued
there's even more elimination or
reversal of the method to which i
constantly and rigorously restricted
myself he gives one to believe actually
that i secretly start from conclusions
previously admitted from an irrational
faith that i would be then concerned
with introducing defending making it be
desired
but in accordance with the scientific
critical philosophical spirits demand i
have from the introduction through the
course of the entire work
constantly proceeded by an indirect and
negative way by examining all of the
solutions that were removed only under
an imperius's imperious logics and a
vital demands double constraint
i had always therefore stood rigidly
against the conclusions at which i was
constrained to arrive
and these conclusions themselves what do
they consistent do they propose a single
one of the assertions that compose
christian dogma
not in the least i introduced nothing i
enter nowhere into the least content of
the catholic religion i stop at the
threshold and as a philosopher i forbid
myself finally to pronounce a single
little word that i would have to say as
a believer since one speaks of partipi
of theses admitted a priori of
irrational apologetics on whom then does
this reproach fall
i have to add as well that what i'm
noting is not just my personal view if
in 1893 paul janet became as he told me
annoyed with my dissertation it is not
at all because it would have seemed to
him to sin against philosophical method
and philosophical spirit
rather to the contrary
he saw himself forced to recognize quote
the rationalism of my means ending up in
what he called the irrationalism of my
solutions this is why he did not refuse
me my vo his vote despite it costing him
seeing a case reopened he had believed
and wanted definitively settled that of
separated and closed philosophy
gabrielle seal told me that nearly to
the end of my work he'd approved of the
truly philosophical development of the
discussion without predicting what would
come out of it but this final deception
had not rendered it wrong no more than
henri barrio and victor broshaw seeing
that emil boutrow was right when he
assigned to read the manuscript had
asked permission to print a dissertation
that would not have had obtained the
favorable unanimity of the judges even
those fundamentally hostile
if they had believed to see there only a
disguised apologetics
louis lillard at first hesitant had
entrusted me with a chair
only
after having been convinced of the
philosophical character of a research
proposing to the audience of all free
minds a problem one can exclude only by
mutilating
reason itself
and this is what the review recognized
in 1894 following the letter that it
welcomed in its own supplement to in
which i responded to a first
interpretation that some resolute
opponents addressed to me becoming
friends at that time the re-edition of
the vocabulary technique it critiqued
the philosophy has eliminated the
exclusion frederick rau earlier in the
discussion of the term oxyo had
expressed against a doctrine he did not
accept though he amicably wrote to me he
did not fail to recognize its
incontestable philosophical character
i will now perhaps surprise my readers
by declaring that if i confine myself to
saying what mr brahir attributes to me
or even if i had nothing else to propose
than what i've published i would have
had to concede to my critic quite more
than the preceding argumentation gives
one to suppose
in 1896 in a letter published by the
anal the philosophy cretien which i
would always prefer to have seen
entitled anal catholic philosophy i had
always i had with a youth youthful
intrepidity that i must ask pardon for
now maintain that in the rigorous sense
of its term christian philosophy does
not exist i withdraw that too hasty
judgment about the object of the present
discussion in the bulletin dissociate
frances de philosophie in which appears
my letter written in march 1931 to mr
jose and in soon to appear in assumed to
appear callier to the nouvelle journey
and particularly in a chapter of the
book that i devote to the esprit cretien
here i can add only one point
mr brahir finds nowhere in history and
in his thought a place for christian
philosophy
but that is because he seeks it where it
is not where it cannot be
in a sort of concordance
forcibly equivocal perilous even ruinous
for philosophy and for religion
here is a case still a little
illuminated but one that dominates all
the other cases of conflict confusedly
setting at odds the two spiritual powers
that seem to oppose each other when it
should be a matter of procuring their
free and fertile cooperation
one imagines that a philosophy in order
to be christian has to has need to
proceed by coincidences super
impositions or servitudes it is exactly
the contrary that is true
far from being impoverished or
submitting to an intrusion
philosophical thought
has only to carry its examination all
the way through to knowledge of its own
deficiencies and limits in order to
prepare that intellectual disposition
with which every sincere mind can be
equipped so as to participate in the
invisible soul of truth
it is such a disposition of a universal
and salutary value rather than a
notional concordance whose development
is complete as possible we have to
secure
and it is on that word of hope and of
agreement i would like to finish these
explanations too long
and too short at the same time
so
that is maurice blondel's short article
um is there a christian philosophy
published in the reviewed metaphysical
dilemma
in in 1931 a response to emil brahie's
criticism of him a response to emil
brellier in general and that finishes
out
part one
of the the book which has to do with the
first phase of the christian philosophy
debates
next time we will start reading from
part two the debates expand 1932 to 1933
with looking at gabriel marcel's
regarding the spirit of medieval
philosophy by mr etienne jill song
published in the nouvelle review de june
in 1932
and uh we we have a lot more yet to go
as you can see looking at the book
the bulk of it is yet to come
um
so there's there's a lot going on
in there all right so let's take some
some questions um
lucas has been watching your aristotle
lectures lately i'm a christian i love
you of all these videos on youtube to
watch and contemplate
yeah i've been you know this is my 10th
year uh or no i've been doing this for
10 years this is my 11th year of being
on youtube and
and i'm gonna keep cranking away i have
no intentions of
stopping anytime soon probably go for
another decade or two health you know
remaining good and all that so
joseph how does blondel's essay on
history and dogma fit into his ideas
about christian philosophy but has to do
more with theology and his his uh his uh
essay history and dogma also has to do
with tradition and it has implications
for
um his views on christian philosophy as
does as he mentioned the letter on
apologetics both of which you find
together in the same
translation by uh drew and trethawn
right those are early works um axiom
1893 uh history and dogma letter on
apologetics the
logic of the moral life
all of those are from what we call
blondel's first period right
and the christian philosophy debate
stuff is really from his his second
period uh he's he's reconsidering some
of the conclusions as a matter of fact
he mentions
a piece that's coming out in the caied
nouvelle journey
and
um the the piece that he's talking about
there is actually a book i've got a copy
of which i should i should have brought
out here
you can take a look at it
um in which he actually goes through his
letter on apologetics and says i got
this part right i got this part wrong
and then he goes into into a lot of
other stuff
and we're going to talk about the
reception of that book later on in in
this piece as well
so i mean with blondel like with a lot
of other systematic thinkers there's
lots of projects going on but they're
all
essentially centered by the same
overarching goal and and blondel
articulated in this piece philosophy
should be truly philosophy christianity
should follow through its its logic to
you know the fullest extent and the two
of them are compatible but not in a
simplistic way the way that a lot of
people just take some ideas from
christianity and plunk them into
philosophy blondel says that's a bad
idea
you have to have a philosophy that has
sophisticatedly
and you know sort of honestly developed
itself to realize where it has gaps
where it needs something more and the
christianity can't just be some sort of
you know ideology that then gets
superimposed on on philosophy
ricky asks what is apologetic so
apologetics is a general term for using
reason to simply argue a case that you
you're already convinced of and so you
know it we can talk about christian
apologetics um blondel you know turns
the thing on to brighier and says buddy
you're basically an apologist for a
hellenism that's just as irrational even
if you're pretending to be a philosopher
as christian apologetics is and you know
i would actually suggest getting
blondel's letter on apologetics where he
says okay we could have a good kind of
apologetics all this other stuff that
these christians are doing this is not
actually good apologetics it tends to um
produce conformism rather than an actual
like you know real ascent
to to things so
yeah so good good questions any other
questions about the the work or
the topics blondel
the other thinkers
we're at the nearly the half hour point
um
this is
quite a takedown you know of of
breijiere i mean bray here basically
doesn't show his face in the debates
after
jill so and blondel you know
tear him a new one
philosophically speaking
um and it's it's thinkers like blondel
and jill so who are going to go on and
make more of an impact than than right
here the other main rationalist
brunchfig is going to be bringing out
some articles you notice i talked about
the review to metaphysique morale that
was really the flagship um french
journal for philosophy
at the time
um there were others that were important
but review physique morale was was kind
of like you know the top tier
journal and so a lot of these these guys
publishing in that is is very
significant i mean it's it's significant
that blondel has enough juice to be able
to you know write to the um
the director the the editor of the
review and says you know i would not
solicit your hospitality if i'd not
received multiple letters i'm gonna you
know make recourse your ever welcoming
friendship and we'll publish this this
you know response by me
in the journal so everybody knows what
what my position is
that's you know a lot of the people
involved in these debates were
among the the elite in the philosophical
establishment
[Music]
all right so joseph asks what are the
primary differences between blondel
stages of thought um they're not really
differences it's more a matter of
elaboration you could say
so the early blonde l is already
incredibly complex and fertile you know
and you you want to look at accion 1893
if you can read french um there's
there's also the carnet on team his
notebooks from the time when he's
working on this stuff and then you know
like i mentioned lettering around
apologetics history and dogma logic of
the moral life
um we would also probably
include a few of the other earlier
essays in there
and blondel's has set his main issues
that he's he's interested in
figuring out how to
respond to
the contemporary movements in philosophy
which
most catholic thinkers hadn't done a
very good job with and you know a lot of
catholic thought was circling around
tomism at the time which was fairly
relatively new to several generations
since since uh there was a revival of
talmism
um
in the late late 19th century and it
became kind of the the regular kind of
thing
blondel gets accused of modernism he
uses the opportunity to explain you know
his position in some of his later
writings then the second phase would
would really begin with with that and it
includes his engagements in the cement
social discussions
um all the way into like the the 20s and
early 30s
he has a book on mysticism that comes
out he has uh you know this stuff and
the
um problem the philosophy catalytic that
comes out so that's like the middle
phase
and then with the last phase which runs
let's say arbitrarily from 1933
to his death in 49 he's bringing out the
massive metaphysical trilogy
of uh
la pansei
laxion the new revised laksian and le
lezet which is actually five volumes and
then some other major works as well and
a lot of occasions pieces
and
he moves away from what he earlier
called the method of imminence which is
a essentially a kind of phenomenology
um into what he calls the method of
implication is there vast differences
between them i don't i don't see vast
differences it's more like you know
further development of of his his
thought and blondel is uh
you know really a major thinker in the
um late
19th century all the way into the mid
20th century in french thought he's not
very well known over here
because he's often
looked at as a um
uh
you know a what would you call it a um
you know
an apologist as a religiously committed
thinker and and i think the
english-speaking world was kind of
allergic to that
um but he had massive influence uh
across the the the
french
thought
um
it's interesting too because when we see
like people remarking about
the french turn to you know back to
religion and phenomenology in the 90s
if you know anything about french
thought you're like there wasn't any
turn people have been doing this the
entire time it didn't get reinvented
with john luke mario and michelle henry
you know uh what about paul record what
about maurice blondel what about uh
gabrielle marcel what about all these
other other people atn born you know um
so there's there's a lot of
here's here's where i'll wrap this up
there's a vast difference between
continental philosophy and then actual
european philosophy what we call
continental philosophy here is like a
narrow little window into the vastness
of what is actually happening in europe
and uh oftentimes we have to turn to to
other perspectives to understand what's
what's really happening over there and
not not you know
go after what's trendy and what's
getting translated into to english and
again i i translated the stuff that's in
here in part because it needed to be
translated you know
all right any other any other questions
people want me to tackle and drink some
water
i've been talking since uh
the early morning
ricky does blondel mention any of the
early christian philosophers uh yeah
um not in not in this letter
um but in in plenty of other places yeah
and when we talk about the early
christian philosophers a lot of people
you know they immediately go back to
augustine but augustine is actually you
know
a late comer patristically right we have
justin martyr and tatyan and lactancias
and
uh clement of alexandria and all these
other you know great thinkers who are
explicitly philosophers and working in a
philosophical thing and then we have
other people who you know in the the
early middle ages were
were called philosophers like john
cassian even though he's a monastic
figure uh monasticism was called the
christian philosophy so yeah blondel
talks about these people but he's very
concerned that we don't just like say oh
well christian philosophy is exactly
what these people
back in you know
200 a.d
or 1200 a.d said it was because we live
in a a modern culture so it's not that
we throw them away
but we can't just um simply follow them
out
um and and reimpose them this was
particularly a problem with tomism at
the time that that blondel was writing
there was something that you could
almost call like a fundamentalism of the
summa you know the idea that thomas has
all the answers we just got to find the
right spot in the summer where he talks
about it
and
yeah there's still a good bit of that
going on today as well
all right any other questions comments
clarifications
all right well i think i will wrap this
up at this point and go get myself some
some lunch um i've been
on with one thing or another with
classes clients or events since uh the
morning
and i'm gonna take a little break have
some lunch and then get ready for the
rest of my day thanks for all the
questions and comments
and i hope all of you enjoy it we'll be
picking up with this again
uh moving into the next part um
in in our next session and we're making
some good progress uh it's taken a while
but uh yeah all right i'll see all of
you somewhere in the ether